get visually BioShock Infinite was
already really impressive but it really
grabbed me at Beach Boys acapella
BioShock Infinite the BioShock Infinite
is the third Bioshock game in the
Bioshock series and its really a
standalone game you don't have to have
played the other Bioshock games to
really jump into this game and know
what's talking about there are a couple
of Easter Eggers type things in the game
we're fans of Bioshock you'll be like oh
I get that that's cool for the most part
though it's its own game you can jump
right into BioShock Infinite
so when BioShock Infinite you play as
Booker DeWitt he's a badass he's kind of
broken and damaged you know those cool
characters that I love he is told to go
to Columbia to get this girl bring her
to us your debts that you owe from
gambling they're all Paige like Cole go
to Columbia where's Columbia it's in the
sky Columbia is a floating city in the
clouds it's really impressive looking
now it's like old school 20th century
America you know boardwalks and empires
and all that good [ __ ] but it's floating
in the clouds and I think it's really
cool that in the original BioShock you
go down to this hellish place BioShock
Infinite you go up to this heavenly
place the place is really perfect
everyone's like Oh g'day mate how you
doing pop come get you pop going
nothing's bad here everyone loves
everybody as always a place that perfect
is not really that perfect it has really
dark secrets and you run into one of
those dark secrets and then everyone
starts attacking you and [ __ ] it's real
you're like whoa first half an hour of
this game you're just exploring like all
this is cool then it gets violent as
[ __ ] after that [ __ ] gets real and
you're like oh yeah it's a Bioshock game
still that's right as for the gameplay
in BioShock Infinite it's really good it
does have that gameplay style that
forces you to find two guns that work
for you because you can only carry two
guns
kinda like Uncharted style what I like
about this though is usually when games
use that style it's like oh here's your
two-handed gun and you have your
one-handed gun choose any combination of
those but it has to be a two-handed gun
and a one-handed gun BioShock Infinite
two guns whatever you want you want a
bazooka and a shotgun you can have it
Magnum and a pistol whatever rifle
sniper rifle shotgun sniper rifle
whatever so this is a combination of two
guns you are all good and as cool as it
is that there are a lot of guns in this
game let's face it four guns really are
the ones that matter the shotgun the
sniper rifle the carbine and the hand
cannon because it's called a hand cannon
it's worth having you will stick to any
combination of two of those four guns
the rest of the guns don't really matter
and of course you have your sign
magic abilities these ones are really
cool too you can upgrade them to make
them cooler and they have more abilities
that happen with them like you have
crows that you shoot out of guys you
will use the crow bone a lot it's pretty
awesome
the crows trap pecking at them and they
stun them so you can just pick them off
but if someone dies while crows are
pecking them they become crow traps and
more guys step on the crows and the
crows start pecking them they die they
make more crow traps which makes more
crows I loved the crows and yeah trap
isn't just you don't have an ability
that's a trap every ability if you hold
down the button is now you can make it a
trap love that good goal and you have
these mods one for a hat one for a vest
one for pants one for boots you get
these clothing items that give you
different abilities and they work
together in certain combinations to the
point where I have a friend who played
the game completely differently because
he had a different set of clothing
combinations than I had he had a mod
where if a guy died from extreme damage
he would stun everyone around him then
he would kill those guys and they would
stun more guys and they would stun more
guys and it kind of went out from there
I really built up my melee melee you
don't select a weapon just a one button
hit it's just triangle BAM melee but I
had mods to where my melee was set up to
where I could reach three times farther
than normal melee so I would shoot
someone get him down to rock and kill
him with melee hidden with my melee I
had another mod if I killed him with
melee I got life and I had a mod that
gave me a 40% chance of getting salt
which is pretty much man and when a guy
died so boom kill life mana rinse and
repeat there are so many combinations
that you can do that I'm telling you I
could play through the game again I will
play it differently replay value key in
any game really and you ride this
skyrail thing the sky rail is pretty
cool I didn't write it as much as I
thought I would but it looks like a big
roller coaster track and you can hook on
to that and just ride through and start
killing guys do aerial kills it's a cool
mechanic of the game it wasn't as
prominent as I thought it was gonna be
but it still is a cool extra as for the
story of BioShock Infinite it's great
it's one of the best you will play in a
first-person shooter
strike that I'm pretty sure it's the
best you will play in a first-person
shooter this guy this prophet of
Columbia his name is Comstock he has
this girl in the tower so you need to go
to the tower to get the girl you need to
save the princess ultimately and I love
that about this game it's an old school
the knight is going to save the princess
from the tower that's being guarded by a
dragon oh it's not a dragon it's the
songbird thing it's a big mechanical
bird and he's scary as [ __ ] when this
bird comes out you're like let's run
let's do that it has some of those
uncharted 2 moments where you're playing
through the action scene and it's
intense because it's all first-person
you feel like you are there as for
Elizabeth she's
awesome I don't think I'm supposed to
have a crush on a game chick who
actually doesn't exist but I do and her
name is Elizabeth from BioShock Infinite
she's just really fun it's like stop
being like Natalie Portman from Garden
State but also like Belle from Beauty
and the Beast adult man ladies and
gentleman and she's useful too she takes
care of her own she doesn't have to be
protected you'll be shooting guys you'll
be like I'm running out of ammo she'll
be like hey I got some ammo and she'll
throw it to you and you'll be like
that's exactly what I needed right then
and there at that time thank you for not
being a useless game chicken thank you
for being hot to its best of both worlds
and and that ain't bad BioShock Infinite
is obviously the opposite Bioshock game
what makes humans human what makes
humanity humanity and how dark can it
get it shows the religious aspect to
that same psychological spectrum
Bioshock 1 shows what happens if a
really ambitious person breaks away from
any country to see how far he can
advance Humanity was science with no
rules binding him BioShock Infinite
shows what happens if someone breaks
away in that same way but advances in a
religious aspect both scenarios end with
two things someone with a god complex
and the rest of us get a suite Bioshock
game this game takes twists and turns
the likes of which you wouldn't even
expect in a game like this one of the
most enjoyable things for me was that I
went into this game not knowing what the
general gist of the game was so when I
played it I was like holy [ __ ] and I'm
not gonna take that away from you guys
which means I'm also not going to talk
about the ending of BioShock Infinite in
this video I do want to make a video
talking about the ending of BioShock
Infinite but being one guy in a one-man
production here on my channel it's
difficult to talk about everything so I
would like to but I don't wanna make
promises but I really would like to I
can't wait to play it again it's one of
those games you want to play it again
immediately knowing that you know
everything in the game just for a
different experience on that end it's
less survival horror than Bioshock it's
not like that horror game that Bioshock
was it's an awesome first-person shooter
but it's a really good and intriguing
story so you're not like I lost the
whole horror aspect because the writing
and the genius of the storytelling just
sucks you in you're like I don't care
it's like everything was put into
BioShock Infinite not thinking about
setting it up for a sequel not thinking
if a sequel could happen but making
BioShock Infinite the best game possible
I love it when storytellers do that it
shows that they care this is a strong
contender for Game of the Year 2013 I
would not be surprised if it wins games
they have their work cut out for them
for this year and BioShock Infinite is
awesome tacular
I can't ruin much for it I really want
to talk more about the game trust me on
this though it's awesome right so
BioShock Infinite have you played it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more